how to make a youtube video introduction
so I got a great question from one of my
YouTube viewers love you guys Valarie
who wrote in to say hello Evan any
suggestions of what I could do for a
YouTube introduction I got to do some
thinking about this and really need help
and don't have the budget yet to hire
somebody to help me would you give me
some suggestions or send me you doing
yours again so can watch again thanks
Evan Valerie so guys it's a great
question and don't worry about having to
go and hire somebody okay you can do a
great video on your own the key is that
it's passionate and personal and some of
the best videos out there are not super
high budget but you can connect with
that person that's the key you have to
make that connection to somebody so how
do you do it here's what I would do
number one start with a powerful opinion
what are you staying for who is Valerie
why are you here what is so important
what is wrong with the world right now I
want you to share a powerful opinion to
make me see if if I agree with you and I
want to stay subscribe to your channel
or if I think hey you know Bradley's
full you have to lunch and I'm gonna go
somewhere else because most people in
their videos are boring they're vanilla
most people in their marketing the
marketing your companies is boring
there's nothing that makes you stand out
versus anybody else so stand for
something important because the people
will feel the same way will flock to you
like minded people will flock to you and
say yeah that's our leader I agree I
want to be a part of this thing that
she's creating so tell me what you stand
for and when you say it it's gotta have
passion and excitement it's sometimes
hard speaking in front of the camera
because there's no there's no audience
right but I'm matching a conversation
you're having with a friend about a
topic that's really important to you
some of the things are you're going to
be sharing on your channel that friend
is in front of you now not the camera
speak to me like that and get excited
and get passion this video will probably
take you a lot of takes okay you won't
get it done in your first take that's
okay let me take you 50
100 takes to get it right but you got to
have that energy it's got to be
something you're feeling in the moment
and then also when you watch it again
and you see yourself talking you get
excited so yeah that's why I'm doing
this right that's where you need to lead
with some passion number to tell your
story who's Valerie why are you doing
this why should I care where did you
come from
why does this mean so much to you tell
me a story I'm not a boring resume story
right like I worked at a company from
1995 to like nobody cares about that
stuff tell me a story that connects to
your mission and also gives me a
teachable lesson I'm gonna learn from it
somehow through your story I'm going to
become a better person I'm gonna learn
something new so an example so I I work
with entrepreneurs I believe in
entrepreneurs right it's easy to know
what I stand for as a story I might say
I'm I talk about when I was first
starting up and I had my business and I
was making $300 a month and not able to
survive and eating beans for lunch every
day and feeling like my self-worth was
being crushed my soul was being stamped
on and not getting any momentum after
feeling like I'm working so hard for
this why am I not seeing any results and
I got a job offer from what seemed to be
a dream job only a couple years ago to
make 80 to $100,000 and travel the world
and do what I thought I wanted to do and
somehow I I didn't know what they wanted
to do should I run my company where I'm
sucking and not making any results and I
feel like garbage or should I go for
this dream job that I always wanted and
something kept me at I want to take this
business and I want to turn it into
something because I didn't want to live
with regret I didn't want to live with
regret and see somebody else make tons
of money off this idea and then I ended
up with some crappy job you know where
I'm working 80 to 100 hours or somebody
else
and regret not having the courage to go
and follow my dream and and do my own
business so that's me that's a story I
might talk about I share lots of stories
in my videos and the teachable lesson
there is don't live with regret right
don't live with regret so tell me your
story
tell me your story that connects with
your audience and give me a teachable
lesson that I can learn from it so that
also should be passionate and when
you're talking about it you get you get
moved especially we're talking about a
hard time in your life number three tell
me what I'll get so if I come and
subscribe to your channel what am I
going to get what are you gonna give me
is it a are you doing interviews or is
it an opinion piece or you're launching
music videos like what's gonna happen on
your channel and how often it's going to
come out is it everyday every week once
a month what is it give me some
expectations so in that third part
you're telling me if I subscribe to your
channel here's what I can expect right
and it may change over time and if that
changes and maybe you do a new video
welcome right and you'll get better
every time you do it and then finally I
would just connect with the audience and
let them know how important everything
is to you your how important their
involvement is that you want them to
comment and you want them to get
involved and you value their feedback
there's so many people who I've left
comments on their YouTube videos and I
never get a response they'll never get a
thumbs-up don't know if it even makes a
difference for them and then others who
you leave a comment and you get a
response right away and and you ask them
to do a video on the make a video
response just like this great you wrote
into me you asked me for help to make
youtube intro and here I am answering
your question right so you want to be
open and accessible make people feel
welcome so sharing a little bit at the
end saying you welcome their feedback
you'd love to help them out if they have
questions leave a comment and we'll get
a video response and thank them for
joining and when you're saying thank you
I genuinely feel it like thank you thank
you so much for joining us and thank you
for joining my channel because it seems
distant right
you're gonna feel great when somebody
subscribes to your channel so try to try
to be in that moment where somebody just
clicked subscribe or somebody's left a
great comment on one of your videos and
channel that to say thank you and really
feel it in the moment so that's my
advice to create a great YouTube intro
don't worry if it sucks at the start
just keep practicing you will get better
and when you do put it out send it to me
because I'd love to see you believe so
as you're watching you like the video
please consider clicking on the link in
the description to support me you can
leave a comment and let me know what you
think and click on my face subscribe to
the channel thank you so much I'll see
you soon